hey developers you know what really
grinds my gears when I'm at a store and
I realize I forgot that fifteen percent
off coupon I got in the mail or the gift
card I got for my birthday when I'm at
the register and I can't remember which
phone number to use with my loyalty card
it's 2016 folks there's got to be a
better way well that's where you come in
with save to Android pay deep links it's
now easier than ever for you to digitize
your loyalty program gift cards and
offers once you do that I can start
storing them on my phone so they're
always with me and ready to use the
easier it is for me to save the more
likely I am the shop so we both win to
get you started I'll show you how to
digitize a loyalty card and add it to an
email so that it's super easy for a
customer to save it first you'll need to
create a save to Android pay deep link
step 1 create a class step 2 define the
object in JSON step 3
create the JSON web token or jot by
signing with your private key step 4
place the jot and class ID in the deep
link URL seen here and now that you've
created the deep link put it behind a
button in an email when a customer gets
your email they can simply tap on the
Save to android pay button confirm and
boom their loyalty card will be
instantly added to Android pay what's
that no more entering phone numbers at
checkout so I've just shown you how to
embed the save to Android pay deep link
in an email but did you know you can use
it anywhere a link works including SMS
your website or your Android app and
once a customer saves your digital cards
to Android pay you can use our REST API
to provide them with really cool
real-time info including how many
loyalty points they've earned their gift
card balance or their offer redemption
status I'd like to see you do that with
a physical card so what are you waiting
for check out our tutorial on how to get
started in a few short hours your
customers can start saving your loyalty
program gift cards and offers to Android
pay so they'll never lose track of them
again plus it'll be easier than ever for
them to use these items at your store
they can have the cashier scan the
barcode or if you've implemented smart
tap they can simply tap their phone to
the terminal